では よろしくお願いします
私のカバンどこでしたっけ？時計はないね
今日は本堂になりましたので
なんか説法をするような気分になりまして
説法だったら大体1時間ぐらいで終わりますけど
はい えーと まああまりこちらには見えませんので
まあ今日は自殺願望の分析というテーマにいたしました
皆様に知られているテーマは同じですかね
自殺願望と人殺いの違いというのがもともと発表されている
うん で あの まあ皆様も一緒に参加して
いろいろアイデアを交換したり
話し合ったりした方が早く終わるかもしれません
私はずっと説明しちゃうと
いろんなことを言っちゃいますからね
下の行は何でしたっけ？ 自殺に追い込まれることは自然の摂理
自殺に追い込まれることは自然の摂理です
だから もう初めからもうこの自殺願望というのは何かすごいおかしいとは思う必要ないんです
すごいごく自然な気持ちなんです
まあそのそれが結論なんです
で それはどういうことかと
自然の摂理ですからね
みんなにあるはずなんです
なんでまた自殺してないのかとわかりませんだけど
はい 皆持っている自殺願望
どなたか一行も読んでくれませんか
煩悩がある限り 生命は無限に輪廻転生を繰り返す
うん 一番目はまあまあ
生命は誰でも煩悩があるんだから
あの ずっと輪廻転生していくんです
もうこのマイクロフォンを持って読むことになるかもしれません
老人だからなかなか斜めに読めないんです
そういうことで あの 我々は煩悩がある限り輪廻転生しているんですね
それぐらいのことはね
あまり説明なくてもわかると思います
その原因は無明と渇愛である
なんで我々は輪廻転生するのかというと
我々は無明ありますし
渇愛というものがあります
これがパーリ語でアヴィッジャというのは無明なんです
タンハというのは渇愛なんですね
このタンハっていうのは大体欲だと私たちは一般的に仏教用語で思ったりしますよ
本当に欲にもタンハという言葉を使いますよ
もう性欲にもタンハという言葉を使うんだから
なんかちょっとややこしくなっちゃうんです
もう確かに欲という意味でもタンハありますけど
やっぱりタンハのこの言語的な意味は乾いた状態って意味なんです
お釈迦様はその意味で使っているんです
言語学的に辞書を調べると出てくる意味で
それで喉が渇いたということは
パーリ語で同じ言葉を使うんです
タシナとかね ですから
このタンハと喉が渇いた状態というのは
欲っていうのになったのは二次的なんですよ
我々は喉が渇いちゃうと
もう水が欲しくて欲しくてたまらんでしょうに
それで生きてる上で何かに乾いちゃうと
それが欲しくて欲しくてたまらんですね
それで欲というんですね
それでこの次何でしたっけ？ 満たしていない気持ち
再び欲しいがあるのは渇愛の一般的な意味
はい 満たしてない気持ち
再び欲しがる気持ちは渇愛の一般的な意味なんですね
それで それについて釈尊の解釈ってどうなっているんでしょうかと
釈尊は 3つに分けられ分けられますよ
この渇愛ということ 欲ではないんだから
一応 3つに分けられますね 1
番目はカーマタンハ カーマっていうのは五欲ということで
この前も説明したんですけどね
金曜日は昨日 昨日だからもう忘れちゃったでしょ
えーで 五欲っていうのは我々は５つのものを欲しがるんですよ
見るものを欲しがる 聞くものを欲しがる
それから嗅ぐものを欲しがる
それから味わうものを欲しがる
それから体に触れるものを欲しがる
そう言うと なんか本当かな？と疑問がありますよ
でも皆様方 例えばすごい可愛い美しい服が欲しがる
それが欲なんですけど
なんでって言えば あれは可愛い見た目
それで見るものなんですよ
あ この色は綺麗だとかね
このデザインは綺麗だとか
私に似合うとかね そういういろんなことで
それは見る楽しみなんですよ
だから 店でブランド品の服が欲しがっちゃうと
もう明らかに見る楽しみなんですね
別に観測の楽しみじゃないんですよ
現代ある服っていうのはどっちでも同じ観測なんですよ
観測はそんなに悪くないんです
昔だったらね 麻で作ったものとかね
いろいろあったんだから
もう感触は悪くて かゆくてもうたまらんとかね
そうするとすごい微妙な感触の服を絹とか欲しがりますよ
現代はそれはないんですよ
もう木綿のものを着たって
もう繊維 もう何製品 化学製品の服を着たっても
大体感触っていうのは同じなんですね
まあ木綿の方がちょっと涼しく感じるし
化学製品っていうのはちょっと暖かく感じるだけで
それも冬になってくると悪く悪いわけじゃないし
ですから 我々は服を買う場合はあまり感触は期待しないんですが
えーと 何でしたっけ？見た目見る楽しみを期待する
それでどこか行ってしましょうかという場合は何なのかと
大体かっこいい店選ぶでしょう
明るくてかっこいい店選ぶ
その時は見る楽しみなんです
もし店員さんも若くて
すごいもう明るくて活発にサービスするならば
そちらへんに結構群がっちゃうんですね
その場合も見る楽しみとかね
しゃべる楽しみとか そういうもの入ってるんですよ
で 料理選ぶ時でも美味しいかね
食べなきゃわからないのに
結局は見て 目で決めるんでしょうしね
だからよくよくで言っても
結局は我々は見るもの
聞くもの 嗅ぐもの 味わうもの
体に触れるもの 欲しがっているんです
それが五欲なんですね
それ分かりやすいんですね
外の世界のものに依存して楽しむこと生きすることです
それで我々は生きているんだ
生きているんだと言ったって
もう何してるんですかね
ご飯食べたり 寝たり もう服を着替えたり
どこかへ出かけたり まあそれでしょうね
だから結局 外の世界にあるもの５つに依存していることが生きることなんです
だから これは輪廻の原因なんです
美味しいご飯食べたいなと思うことも
綺麗なものを見る と思うことも
結局は輪廻の原因になるんです
で 生き続けるんだから
それで もう食べたいんだから生きてる人々もいるでしょうに
で 世間一般的に言う欲なので理解しやすい
まあそれは世間一般的な欲なんです
これ 1番目 はい  2番目
2番目はババタンハ それは存在欲なんですね
昔は右翼とね 漢文にあったこともありました
右翼と言ったって何か分からないんですから
存在欲と言えばまあ分かると思います
これが生き続けたい 死にたくないと思う衝動ですね
まあ死にたくないでしょう
これがババタンナーなんですよ
だから誰でもそんなにも死にたくはないとかね
そんなに怯えてないんですよ
例えばこのもうイラクとかなんか言ったら
やっぱり死にたくないというふうに気づくかもしれませんだけど
で 日本にいると別に死にたくないとかね
そんな怯えがないんです
死ぬわけないんだそうと思ってるんだから
しかし ちょっと考えれば
我々死にたくないっていうことはまあ持っているんです
で 電車が来ると まあ黄色い線のところに下がって待っているとかね
ホームの先っぽまでは絶対行かないでしょうね
なぜかというと 死にたくないんですよ
信号無視して道路を渡ろうとはしないでしょう
まあどうせ車止まってくれるだろうと
そういうチャレンジは賭けはしないんですね
なぜかというと もし止まってくれなかったらどうしますかね
だから死にたくないんですよ
だから死にたくないという衝動はどんな生命にもあります
次何でしたっけ？ けど
未来があることだと考えて
人生は人生は楽しんで生きるからの生きるほど楽しめなかったからも現れてくるのです
そうそう ババタンナーという存在欲はどんな時現れるかというと
例えば人生は楽しんでるから
すごい生きることは楽しくてたまらん
もう家族は可愛いし 子供は可愛いし
友達はいっぱいいるし
お金もあるし もう毎日おいしいご飯食べてダンス大会でもやったりして生活するとやっぱり死にたくないでしょ
だから人生をすごく楽しんでる人々はもう死にたくはない
できるだけ 1日でも長生きしたいというすごい強烈な渇愛が生まれちゃうんですね
で 逆に納得いけるほど楽しみなかった時
だったら死にたいと思うのは普通でしょ？そう思わないんですよ
やっぱり何とかして納得いきたい
例えば 美味しいご飯全然食べられない人がとにかく頑張って一回だけでも美味しいご飯を食べたいと思っちゃうんですよ
頑張ってでも で 高価なものを買うお金がない人は
一つだけでも金貯めて貯めて買いたいと思っちゃうんですよ
だから人生楽しくなると存在欲が生まれるし
あんまり納得いかない
例えば会社でなかなかあんまり収入が良くなると
もっと頑張らなくちゃっていう気持ちになるんですね
それで楽しめない場合も
同じババタンハ渇愛存在欲が生まれてくるんです
はい とにかく早く終わりたいと思っています
で  3番目 ビバタンハ これは非存在欲と
一応名前をつけないと格好悪いんだから名前を付けたんですが
なかなか理解しにくい単語なんです
生きていきたいという気持ちはわかるんだけど
非存在欲って何でしょうかね
これは理解するのは難しいが
まあ今日のテーマですね
今日の話はそれなんです
このビバワタンハの説明なんです
非存在欲って何なのかと
で まあちょっと読んで次は
破壊欲だとも言います
破壊欲 読むとき間違いあったら直して読んでください
時々まあもう今日は朝作りましたから
全部  この 3つも渇愛として全ての生命に共通なんです
うん だからその 3つ 破壊欲とも言えるし
破壊欲 その 3つは渇愛というんですよ
全ての生命に共通しているんです
ですから 私にもあって
皆様にもある 犬にも猫にもある
この 3愛は 渇愛は お釈迦様はこの初転法輪という初めの説法をした時は
苦しみの原因としてこの三種類の渇愛を教えたんです
だから これは初めの説法にあった内容なんです
それからすごいきめ細かく分析なさって説法してたんですけど
最初はすごいわかりやすく
もうわかりやすくはなかったんでしょうと思いますけど
一応誰もわからなかったんだから
人間にはそういう三つの衝動があるんだぞっていうことが
だからこれは大胆な発見であって
人間に説得するのも大変難しいことなんです
まあとにかくもうこの三つはみんなに共通しています
最後の行は何でしたっけ？ 解脱を体験しない限り
人を悩ます苦しませる原因として生きる
解脱しない限りは解脱するということは三愛をなくすことなんです
カーマタンハ バヴァタンハ
ヴィバヴァタンハ それは根こそぎなくす
取り除く それが完全たる解脱
究極な幸福というんです
これがしていない限りは
我々にはカーマタンハ
バヴァタンハ ヴィバヴァタンハというのはつも
もう結構迷惑はかけています
だから悩ますと言ったら
例えば我々 おいしいご飯を食べたいなと思っちゃうと結構大変でしょうに
楽じゃないんですよ 誰が食わせてくれるんだったらありがたいんでけど
そうはないんだからね
だからおいしいものを探さなくちゃいけないし
お金がかかるわ 料理しなくちゃいけないわ
そうで微妙にいろいろの腕を磨かなくちゃいけないは大変なんです
だからブランドの服やらカバンやら欲しいなと思ったら
これから人生は大変ですよ
例えば生きていきたい
とにかく生きていきたいと思っちゃうと
ものすごい もう何をしてでも生き続きたくなるんですよ
だからこの渇愛は人間には結構人間いじめてるんです
人間を 苦しんでいるんです
だから生きる苦しみっていうのは
この渇愛から生じるんです
はい 読めない  破壊欲は
それでこのヴィバヴァタンハ
この専門用語で覚えてください
ヴィバヴァタンハ 非存在欲ですね
あるいは破壊欲 で 破壊欲
本当に欲ですかと 破壊したいという気持ちは
えーと 一行目何でしたっけ？ 生命を殺したりして快感を感じる
これも欲なんですよ 物を壊したり
もう破壊したり 人をいじめたり
生命殺したりして快感感じるんですよ
怒りっていうのは結構快感なんです
だから欲なんです はい
その快感がある故に生きたくもなるし
そう もう快感だから生きていたって別にいいんじゃないんですかね
だから破壊することは快感で
それで生きる衝動が 生きていなくちゃいけないと
もっと人を殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
もっと破壊しなくちゃいけないんだと
すごい微妙に身を守って生きているんですよ
この破壊する人々も まあ例えばこの自爆テロやらね
なんとか飛行機ハイジャックやら何かしようかと思う人は
誰よりもすごい厳密に自分の自己防衛対策をとるんです
とにかくそれから破壊して快感だからね
それがもう生きる衝動になるんです
だから欲になるんです
はい 基本的には怒りなんです
それ破壊欲っていうのは
このヴィバワタンハっていうのは怒りなんです
強烈な怒りなんです 普段は我々怒って気持ち悪かったって言うでしょうね
だったら怒らなきゃいいでしょう
でもそっちを怒るんですよ
快感があるんだからなんです
欲は正反対の性格ですが
渇愛という概念でまとめると同じになります
うん で 怒りと欲といえば正反対
例えば美しい花を見て欲が出てくる
なんてきれいな花ですかと
まあ死んでる犬の遺体でも見たら
なんて気持ち悪いですかと
で そこで気持ち悪いと思ったところで怒りなんですね
もう逃げたくなるんです
汚いところから 花を見るとそちらに行きたくなるんです
だから正反対なんですよ
性格は 一つは引き寄せる
一つは引き離せる 例えば人間で言えば
あの人はかわいいと思っちゃうと
その人と一緒になりたくなる
仲良くしたくなる あの人は大嫌いやと思っちゃうと
とことんその人から逃げたくなる
いるところにも自分は行きたくなる
行きたくないと思っちゃう
だから離れるか引き寄せるかというまるっきり正反対の衝動なんですが
渇愛でしてみれば同じなんですよ
どちらにしたっても その快感で生き続けるんだから
怒る人はもう怒って怒って怒って足らない
いくら怒ったってもキリがない
もっと怒りたい 欲張る人も欲しい欲しいとことで
いくらあってももっと欲しいと思っちゃう
だから乾いているんですよ
怒っている人も 欲張っている人も
どちらでも乾いている
だから その専門用語でまとめると機能は同じくなるんです
乾いている状態 怒りも乾いている状態
欲も乾いている状態 そういうことで理解してください
それで難しさがなくなると思います
怒りも修行 経典ではたくさんありますが
ヴィパッサナーでは  はい
それから怒りの勉強に入ります
そこ今までの何かポイントについて話したいこと
何かありますか？わからなかったとことか
今まで説明したのは 我々は生かせるエネルギーは何なのかということなんです
平気で言うでしょ 生かして生かされているとかね
生かされている 何か尊く感じるでしょ
生かされているんだと
仏教ではもう渇愛なんです
心にあるこのエネルギーなんです
何かありがたい どなたか我々は大変
哀れんで生かされているわけじゃないんです
自分自身の心にある この欲
カーマタンハ欲望 ババタンハ存在欲
ヴィバワタンハ非存在欲という３つがエネルギーなんです
これが神様です それでヒンドゥー教で三神論なんです
神というのは神で ブラフマ
ヴィシュヌ マヘーシュワラという
まあブラフマ ヴィシュヌ
イーシュワラともいうし
またイーシュワラのと言葉
道義語はもうもっと勢いありますからね
一応一般的にはブラフマとヴィシュヌとイーシュワラ
うん ブッダの時代ではそれほど明確ではなかったんですが
名前はあったんですけどね
ウェンヌーという名前もあり ３
人の名前もありましたけど
あまり性格をはっきりしていなかったんで
当時では どんどん性格をはっきりしたんです
それでブラフマというのは創造神ですね
親ですね すべてのものは現象を作る
その神様が それでヴィシュヌ神様はブラフマはどちらかというと何か父親みたいな存在で
で ヴィシュヌ神様はまあなんか母親みたいな存在にしてあって
維持管理するんです 守るんですね
作ったもの だからブラフマ神様は世界をまあ作るわ作るわ作るわ
もう産みっぱなしで作りっぱなしで
なんかもうワニみたいな卵を産んで握って逃げていくとかね
あの とにかくもう作る
これで後ろからヴィシュヌ神様が来て
この作られたものを一生懸命守る
維持管理する それで最後にシヴァ神が来るんです
その人は何でもかんでも破壊する
何でもかんでも これでうまくバランスを整えているんです
だって破壊しなかったらブラフマ様にはもう仕事なくなっちゃうでしょうに
もうもういいやと あんたを産まなくてもいいやってことになるでしょうに
これでもうシヴァがもう何でもかんでも破壊するんだから
まあブラフマ神様も限りなくもう作りっぱなしで創造しっぱなしで
ヴィシュヌ神様は作っただけでは物事はね
うまくいかないんだから
もう維持管理はもうやっていて
そこで三位一体論がヒンドゥー教で西洋より随分昔が出て構成されてあったんです
それで仏教になってくると
この似ている概念ですけど
ブラフマっていうのは無明って似ているんですね
無知に 心理学的に言えば
我々の心にある無知に随分似ているんです
で いわゆるそれで維持管理することは欲なんですね
私たちは物事を壊したいよりは守りたい
維持したい気持ちがあるでしょう
それは我々欲があるんだからなんです
そこでヴィパッサナー
破壊したいという気持ちも我々の心にある
壊したいと ですから これ貪瞋痴なんですよ
結局は で 痴っていうのはブラフマ神様に似ていて
怒りはシヴァ神様に似ていて
貪りはヴィシュヌ神様に似ているという状態になっています
まあそれもただもう思想的に見ると
そういうふうにまあ合わせてみることはできます
似ている概念は何なのかと
向こうは神様を信仰しているんだから
何でも神でなきゃ説明はしない
こちらは仏教は何でも心理学ですから
心理学的な現象でしか説明しない
しかし実態は同じなんです
実態は 例えば世界を見ると
ずっと現れっぱなしで現れたものはもう何とかして維持管理して長生きさせようとみんな必死で
いくら頑張っても全部潰される
だからその 3つの現象
生住滅という現象は決して消えません
だからそれが各宗教が自分の概念によって説明するだけ
仏教はただそれは生住滅の現象として
心から見れば もうカーマタンナ
ヴァータンナ ボータンナで
あるいは貪瞋痴なんですね
アビダンマ これから怒りの説明
シヴァ神様の説明に入ります
はい  1番目は怒り 単純な怒りですね
どうせどうせと言うんですね
これは阿比達磨の説明で
まあこれは分かり分かりやすい
まあ怒るということ 嫌なことになると怒っちゃうんですね
はい  2番目  2番目はこの嫉妬
嫉妬も怒りなんですね
嫉妬っていうのは嫌なこと起きちゃったんですよ
だから怒っているんです
嫉妬しているんです  3番目はまっちゃり物惜しみ
で これもまあ自分の欲じゃないかなと勘違いするかもしれませんだけど
欲じゃないみたい 自分のものはもう誰も触ったりも
もらったりも使ったりもすることはすごく激しく嫌がる
ですから 自分でも使わない
そういう人は それで怒りなんですね
物惜しみも はい で  4番目
後悔することですね 後悔正しいんですかね
漢字は うん えーと なんかまあ日本ではなんか後悔することっていうのはなんか美徳だと思ってるでしょ？まあまあ美徳だと思うならば
それはそれでいいんだけど
仏教から見れば怒りなんです
これを自分を責めることだからね
認めることじゃないんだから
まあ後悔も怒りももうすごい明らかな怒りなんです
はい それで怒りはこうやって 4つに分けてみる
で 経典ではそういうなんか 4つだけではなくて
いろんなたくさんの言葉があるんですよ
もう書いちゃうと長すぎますから
あまり書いてないんですけど
もっと分かりやすい言葉いっぱい使って
例えば悲しみ 人が亡くなったら悲しいでしょ
泣いたりするでしょ それは仏教お釈迦の経典ではそれも怒りの一種で
で これから憎しみやら恨みやら
そういう悩んだりするでしょ
悩みも執念深いというところも
こういうのも怒りに入ってるんですね
それからなかなかもう何かあったら忘れられないという状態もあるしね
で 悔しいとかね そういう悔しくなる気持ちとかね
そういうものも怒りのいろんな形なんです
それで次になぜ怒るのかという問題です
はい 五欲が気に入らない
1番目は五欲は気に入らない
見たんですけど 五欲の一部でしょ
かっこ悪い 気持ち悪いと言って怒るんですよ
五欲は気に入らない ご飯食べたんだけど
もうおいしくなかったらもう気分が悪いんです
だから怒る 1番目の原因というのは五欲が気に入らない
例えばこちらで誰かがすごい大騒ぎしちゃうと
もう迷惑でしょ 音は五欲の一部なんで気に入らない
その音は だから怒っちゃうんです
イライラするんです だから怒る
第 1の原因は五欲が気に入らなくなっちゃったんです
はい 次 何でした？例ですね
音楽が楽しくなかった
ご飯もおいしくなかった
電車に乗るというのは
電車で足を踏まれた  そういうことで怒るでしょう
足が踏まれたら楽しい人っていうのはいませんしね
だからそうやって自分であった五欲が気に入らない時は怒る
はい 次  ね 欲しいものが
手に入らない そちらも例あると思います
好きな人が結婚している
欲しかったものを買いに行った時
品切れをして  まあそんなもんで
まあ欲しいんだけど 手に入らないんですね
だから流行った五欲は気に入らないか
流行って欲しい五欲が手に入らない
その時も怒るんです 好きな人はいるんですけど
気に入ってる人が でも結婚している
そうすると気分が悪くなるタイプでしょ
はい  欲しいものは自分から離れる
次の原因は欲しいものは自分から離れるということ
それで例 いくつか書いたんですけど
振られる 死に別れ 壊れる
なくなる 盗まれる 他人に取られる
こういうことで誰でも来るでしょう
振られたら結構精神的に落ち込んだりするでしょうに
男性の場合は で 死に別れ
まあこれは大体生臭いでしょう
で 壊れたらどうします？例えば万円で何か高い壺でも買ってきたらね
ちょっと足が滑っちゃって壊れたら
ああ良かったと思わないでしょ
万円の着物を買って これはまあ五年ぶりに着よう着よう着ろうではないかとタンスから出すところで
子どもが何か持ってきて
ぐさっと汗かいて ぱっとその上にこぼしちゃうと
もう着られないでしょうに
えらく腹が立つでしょう
全部価値がなくなったんだから
だからそうやって欲しいものが自分から離れるんですよ
親しい人が死に死んじゃうと
自分から離れるんですよ
それで怒るんです あるいはね
家に強盗に入ったら パーティーやる人は誰もいないでしょう
今日は明智に強盗に入ったんだから
みんなでビールでも飲んで楽しもうぜということはないでしょうに
そんなところじゃない
すごく怒っているんです
だから欲しいものがなくなると自分から逃げて逃げると怒るんです
それも一つの怒りな怒りなんです
はい  欲しいものから自分が離れなくてはならない
それ自分から逃げるだけじゃなくて
自分が出て行かなくちゃいけない時もあるでしょうに
いろいろ訳があったりして
その時も嫌なんですよ
例えば すごいお母さんに可愛がっている子供が
幼園なんでしたっけ あれは
幼稚園に出す時は泣くでしょう
やっぱり母から離れるのは嫌なんですね
それでやりますと  不倫相手の不倫相手が家にバレ退職
離婚などを迫られる  不倫相手のことをね
家にバレちゃうと 自分が離れなくてはいけないでしょ
その人から それで怒るんですよ
だから怒るったっても
自分の奥さんに お前何者なのかというとぶん殴ったりは
だから怒りにいろんな形がありますよ
落ち込んだりして いろいろまあもうもうごめんごめんとか言ったりとか
ごまかしたりしたりとか
言い訳をしたりとか そういうのも全部怒りの形なんです
だからいろいろ怒りがあるんです
例えばもう辞任やらね
まあ不正でも発見隠されてね
まあ退職とか離婚とか責められちゃうと
自分が離婚したくないんだけど
相手が離婚したい そうなっちゃうと怒る怒りが出てきますよ
だから怒りっていうのはいろんな表現しますよ
離婚を迫られたらどうするのかと
その時やること 怒りの表現になります
ですから この自分が出ていかなくちゃいけない
例えば  こちらで友達もできて
あるいは不倫相手でもいいんだけど
仲良くしていて それで外国で仕事をしなさいと会社から飛ばされると
不倫相手も連れて行かれないでしょうに
自分の奥さんも連れて行けないのに
そうするとすごく気分が嫌なんです
外国出張できてよかったというふうに思わないんですどこかで
だから 自分が欲しいものから離れることも怒りの原因になります
また怒りの原因があります
これからは主観的な原因なんですね
1番目は  自分の能力は不適合
自分の能力は何かちょっと世界には生きるためには適合していないんですね
これ結構怒るんですよ
はい  体力の不適合  これいろいろちょっと分析してみたんです
不適合と言っても分からないんだから
1番目は体力の不適合
体力が弱いとかね これ嫌なんですよ
みんな元気で明るく活発で生きているのに
自分に体力はない これ暗くなるでしょ
あの暗くなることは怒りなんです
引っ込むこと はい ２  知識の不適合
知識の不適合 これもありますよ
あの人は頭いいんだけど
私は頭が悪くてうまく仕事がいかないんだとかね
頭が悪くてなかなかみんなと仲良くできないとかね
この知識の不適合 不適合も結構結構ではなくて
必ず怒りの原因になります
自分の頭が悪いと あの試験なんかは合格できるわけがないんだぞとかね
司法試験なんかは受かるわけないんだとかね
そう思うことは知識の不適合なんですね
その時も怒っているんです
はい  才能の不適合  才能の不適合もあります
才能っていうのは別なものなんで
知識よりも体力よりも
この体力と知識っていうのは
このすばりとこの臨機応変で使えることが才能なんです
だから その場でその場で見事にうまく使えるならば
誰でも楽しいでしょう
これがなかなかないんですね
人間で勉強はしているんだけど
才能はない 時々音楽大学も出ているんですけど
音楽の才能はない 技術はできますよ
技術的にはピアノも弾けるし
もう何でもできる 指揮者もできるし
でも音楽的な才能がなければもう売れないんです
だから我々大体ダブっちゃうんですよ
あの人の音楽の才能あるんだと言ったところで
音楽できるんだという意味なんです
音楽ぐらい私にもできますよ
訓練さえすれば ただの肉体の訓練だから
だからそれが知識の世界で才能というのは別なものなんです
才能っていうのは 持っている能力を見事に応用する
びっくりするほどみんなびっくりさせるほど
自分を持っている能力を応用する
それが才能なんです なんで私は日本語まで教えなくちゃいかんかね
本当に今そういう意味なんですよ
もうこの知識に才能って言ってはいけません
はい  世界は期待に応じる
はい 怒る 次のポイントね
1番目は何です？能力の不適合
不適合でいくつか書いたんですね
次に世界は期待に応じない
自分が自分の中を見ると不適合の問題が出てくる
俺には才能がないんだと怒っちゃうんです
自分を見ないで外を見ると世間に文句を言うんです
それでまた怒るんです
それで世間に言う文句はもう期待に応じないんだということなんです
よくお母さんたちがやるでしょ
それが 子供に対しても怒りっぱなしでしょうに
だからそれはもう期待に応じてくれないんだという
自分のせいだと思わないんです
はい  認めてくれない  これがありますよ
認めてくれないんだと
これ 大変な悩みなんですよ
現代人の 私のことを全然認めてくれない
子供もよく悩むんでしょ
父親が全然認めてくれないんだとかね
母親は認めてくれないんだと
悩みっていうことは怒りなんです
で 怒りということをわかるのは
もしこれちょっと強烈になるととんでもないことをするんですよ
暴力を振ったり 親を殴ったりまでするんです
だから認めてくれないと怒るんです
はい  仕事収入は能力に合わない
これがちょっとこの文章でわからないんですね
自分が仕事をしているんですけど
自分にはもっと能力があるんですよ
もっと能力あるんだけど
つまらない仕事をさせられちゃって
嫌でしょ そういうことは
世間ではよくあることで能力あるんですけど
まあ雇われる側がちゃんとこれやりなさいとかね
あんた荷物整理しなさいと言われると
私はそんな身分じゃないんだと
私にもっと能力があるんだということで怒っちゃうんです
あるいはバリバリ頑張って仕事をするんですけど
収入は足らない その時
こんなに仕事をしているのに
この収入は何なのかと
普通だったら 他の人だったらもっとほんのちょっとの仕事でたくさん収入をもらっているんではないかと思っちゃうんですね
それでまた怒るんですよ
はい  環境が合わない  環境が合わないことでまた怒る
この環境が合わないということは
この仲間が合わない 例えば
せっかく入社して会社に入ったんですけど
その人々は何か気に入らなくなっちゃう
性格が合わないんだと
これすごい怒りの原因になります
学校に行ったら 学校の仲間たちが気に入らないと
それ 環境が合わないということなんです
と怒るんですよ 例えば同期はうるさいんだと思っちゃうと
環境が合わないでしょ
もう怒っているんです
田舎に行ったらもう寂しいと
で 環境合わなくなっちゃうんですね
だから環境っていうのは人間も環境であって
自然も環境で合わない時は怒るんですよ
だからそういうことを見ると
大体我々はもう不適合っていうのはもうありあしないほどあるでしょうし
誰でも人間っていうのは私は適合している人だと思わないんですよ
世界を見ると いくらでも自分より能力がある人はいるんだから
これからこのもう世界は期待に応じてくれないというのは当たり前でしょうに
だから怒る原因というのはもういくらでもある
あるのは怒る原因のみですよ
よく考えてみると 怒らない原因っていうのはほとんどないんです
はい 次一体  期待の問題
それからもうもうなぜ怒るのってことで
期待という問題がありますね
ちょっと勉強してみましょう
で 今までのポイントというのはすごい大事ですよ
今まで説明してたところで
なぜ怒るのかっていうことね
だから本当に人間には怒らずに生活できない
もうなんだかんだで怒る原因ばっかりなんですよ
だから赤ちゃんの時から人は怒って怒って怒って生きているんです
気分いい条件というのはなかなか稀で
笑える条件というのは稀なんです
怒ることっていうのはいくらでも原因ありますからね
そこら辺も勉強した方がいいっていうことで
それでこの期待という問題も勉強した方がいいんですね
期待が外れることも怒りの原因
うん 期待が外れると怒る
それは分かりますね はい
病気になる 競争で負ける
落第する 隠したいものは世界にバレる
昇格はできなくなる リストラになる
子供は家出をする  そういうのはいくらかの期待はずれなんですね
全部怒るでしょう 病気になると楽しい？嫌でしょうね
これ怒りなんですよ で
競争で負けたらもう悔しいでしょう
それも怒りなんです だって競争したっていうことは勝ちたかったでしょうに
負けたらもう期待はずれで怒る
で 落第すると怒る 気持ち悪くなる
で 隠していたのにバレちゃうとね
いろんなことを大変な怒るんですよ
悔しくなっちゃって 恥ずかしくなっちゃって
言葉が出なくなっちゃって
いろんなことをしますよ
まあそれは分かりやすいと思いますよ
昇格できなくなる 昇格は期待しているし
できなくなったら気分が悪い
それで自信なくなる それは怒りの結果なんです
怒ったんです はい  期待があればあるほど
怒りの破壊力も大きくなる
それで問題は 期待があればあるほど怒ることというのはいくらでもありますよ
ブッダはこの期待っていうのはすごく良くないんだと
日本では期待がもってよくね
頑張ってなさいと言ってるでしょうに
まあいいんじゃないんですか
取ってないんだから 何もわからへんだから
しかし お釈迦様は逆言ってるんです
これとても危険だと 期待があれ
例えば自分の子供にものすごい高い期待をつけておくと
もう決してうまくいかないんですよ
もういくら怒っても足らなくなっちゃうんですよ
子供はいくら頑張っても母親が怒るんですよ
なぜかというと あまりにも期待しすぎて
子供に対して全然期待していないと
すごい自然に成長する
何のぶつかることもなく
それだったら子供はもう 45点取っても喜びますよ
別に期待してなかったんだから
45点も取ったの？あ
よかったよかったと 自分の子供は天才やとか勘違いしてすごい期待すると 98点で怒るんです
なんでこの 2点は足らなかったんですかと
と怒るんですよ だから期待があるということは
ものすごい自分が持っている怒りの爆弾の破壊力をどんどんアップすることなんです
ものすごく強烈になります
ウランの量がどんどん増えるんです
破壊力が だから本当は期待ゼロだったら立派なんですけど
はい 次のポイント まあもう怒りのどういう怒り？なんで怒るのかっていうことで説明しましたし
それで結論は人間には怒る原因というのは無数に無限にある
怒らないでニコニコと笑っていられることっていうのはなかなか珍しい
ない それぐらい我々は怒りにやられているんです
だから気をつけないと
勉強しておかないと幸せにはなりっこはないんですよ
こういう風に怒りやら精神状態はお釈迦様以外誰も説明してないでしょうに
だからブッダの話を聞かない限りは
もう幸せになるとは期待できません
期待できないんだからありがたいということも言えるかもしれません
もう成り立ちません だから今まで説明したポイントは覚えておくだけで十分ですよ
別に あ こういうことだ
こういうことだと知っただけで落ち着きます
それから怒りが実る時
どうなるのかと  破壊は怒りの結果なんです
怒りっていうのは破壊するんですよ
壊す だから母親が子供に対して怒っちゃうと
母親は子供を壊してるんです
あなたのために怒ってるんではないかとお母ちゃんはと言ったっても
これはためにならないんです
お母ちゃんはお母さん
子供を壊してるんです
で 怒りには破壊ということは決まっているんです
はい  怒りは破壊行為をしないですむ
全くあり得ません  なんかまあ
済むということは全くあり得ません
怒りが起きたら 例えばちょっと怒ったと
自分がまあちょっと怒っただけで大丈夫
大丈夫はないんですよ
怒りっていうのはちょっとでも破壊するんですよ
あの まあこれから来るでしょう
えーと あの あれなんですか
タンスの中に何とか虫
何虫っていうんですかね
名前ないんですかね え？虫のこと
虫の方 虫の方 え？いや
特別な種類いますよ 服を食べる
あのえ？まあ 私に言ったって私も分かりませんし
日本語で名前は とにかくある一種の１種類の虫がいて
もうとにかく服を食べるんですよ
その虫の餌なんですね
だから結構見えますけど
小さいんですけどね 可愛いしね
だから その虫１匹にはまあどうったことはない
そんなたくさん食べられませんよ
小さいでしょうし でも
小さな虫１匹でも衣類に付いているとどうなるんですかね？その虫が食べるんですよ
衣類を 食べないでいちゃうと死んじゃうでしょうに
だから怒りも小さいんだから別にどうったことないということになりません
破壊する だからちょっと早い
ちょっと早すぎですけど
忘れるんだから今言います
ポイントもう一つ この欲も怒りも２つでしょ
原因 欲の場合は欲も悪い結果出すんですよ
怒りも悪い結果出すんですよ
しかし 欲の場合は結果がのんびりなんですね
時々出せない時もあります
怒りがそうじゃないんです
はっきりと結果を出すんです
この例で考えてください
畑作るんだと 豊作にするそうと
これ欲でしょ それでどれぐらい確率ありますかね
100%はないでしょう
もしかすると豊作になるかもしれません
しかし 私はこの家を壊してやるそうと
火をつけてやるそうと
と思って火をつけたら家が破壊する確率性はどれぐらいですかね
100 でしょ だから怒りの結果はいつでも 100 必ず出す
欲の結果っていうのはまあちょっとぬるいんです
この例でまた考えてください
誰かが若い女性と不倫をしている
悪いことでしょう もう不幸になるに決まっている
でも 今日不倫して明日不幸になったってことはないんです
バレてないしね まあ気分もいいし
それでまあずるずるずるずると
1ヶ月間  2年  3年 まあ1年ぐらい経つと
不倫相手はまあもうこの人と一緒にいたんだから
私にはもう将来性なくなったと言って
その人にしがみつくでしょうに
離しませんよとかね それで離婚せめたりするでしょう
それで不倫だけでは住めなくなっちゃうんですね
それで本人が家に言わないと
不倫の女性が家にバラすんですよ
この人の まあバラすようにする
これからですよ 不幸が出てくるのは
だからもう例えば欲で不倫しちゃうと
不幸が出るまではまあ 1年かかったり
半年かかったり 5年もかかったりもします
時々10年かかったケースも日本にありましたからね 10
年も不倫していて やっとバレたと奥さんに
隠し子まで作っていたと
で 欲の場合はそういう風に結果出るの遅いんです
では 電車できれいな女性が見た
その女性をもう殴ったりとかね
だから欲でそういうこともしますよ
まあまあ 女性でなくてもいいんです
自分が道路で人をぶん殴った
これ怒りでしょ 結果は1年経ちますかね
バレるまでは ぶん殴ったことバレるまで1年は経ち
その瞬時にバレてます
その瞬時に悪い結果を受けます
だから怒りは怖いんですよ
すぐもう結果が出る 遊んではいけない怒りとは
これは後で説明するべきでしたけどね
はい だからはい 何でしたっけ？ わずかな怒りさえも十分破壊力を持っている
だからわずかな怒りでも十分破壊力を持ってますよ
小さな虫一匹でも服を食っちゃえば
もう使えないんですよ
はい  大きな怒りの場合は言うまでもありません
うん 地球まで破壊する
はい そうしていきましょう
自殺は最大の怒り  最大の怒りで自殺するんです
何を破壊するかとか まあいろんなものは
だからこれ前書いたんですからね
怒りはね まあ物を壊したりするわ
人をいじめたり殺したりするわ
それ破壊力でしょ それは自分をいじめたりするわ
まあそれで破壊力の最大は自殺なんです
はい  怒りの実はどうでしょうか
うん 怒りは破壊の神様です
怒りっていうのはもう破壊の神様ですね
破壊といえば何ですか？と聞かれたんですけども
何でも破壊する 自分自身まで破壊するんだから
だから怒りは破壊の神様
他の表現ないんですもう
壊しの神様 あのプロダクションの何か作る神様じゃないんです
うん  以下のようにして破壊する
それからこの破壊のやり方
何を破壊するのかという
はい  物の破壊 壊し  物の破壊と壊し
そんなのわかるでしょう
怒りでやってるんです
はい  他人の破壊 いじめ
殺し  他人の他の生命 他の人間をね
もう破壊する もう破壊するって
人間を破壊するっていう場合は
いろんな悪いことをしたりすることでね
いじめたりして また殺したりして
動物も殺したりして それは2番目の破壊なんですね
はい  自分自身の破壊と堕落
それから自分を破壊する
これ1番目はなんか自分を不幸にする
怒りが 堕落する自分が
怒りが出ちゃうともう堕落しちゃうんです
はい  もう自分自身を殺す
それで自分自身を殺す
不幸にするだけではなくて
もう最後に自分自身を殺す
だからまあ 自殺っていうのは怒りなんです
すごい強力ですね 怒りが
これが何を破壊するのかという質問に答えなんです
はい  怒りの実の選び方
それでいろいろあったでしょう
の怒りの種類が 実の種類が
だからこの自己破壊するか
ものを壊すかと選ぶでしょ
人間っていうのは怒ったらその選び方
自分に対する自信が最強
自分に対する自信が最強な人
自分には自信がある その人は何するかと
はい うん  物の破壊  その人は物の破壊選ぶんです
体力もあるし 自信もあるし
だから親を殴るか 家を壊すか
学校を壊すか 窓ガラスを割るか
外へ行って公園に行って
もう何 誰にも目をかけないおじいさんが殺すとかね
あれが自信あるいかりやがやっていることなんですね
それ選ぶんです はい  自信はあるが
怯えが混じる  だからこれ
自信弱い人 なんか自信ちょっとあるんですけど
怯えもあるんですよ だから怯えたり自信があったりすると弱いでしょうに
その人は何を選ぶのかと
他人の破壊  あの 2番目の他人の破壊
殺し選ぶんです 怯えもあるんだから
だから人殺したりするのは臆病者なんです
自信がないんです 怖くなればなるほど
むちゃくちゃ残酷に殺すんです
だってアメリカ軍隊がイラクでもう結婚式であろうが葬式であろうが何でもいいんですよ
もう爆弾落としたり 飛行機から殺したりする
もうかなりの臆病なんですよ
自信ない 我々アメリカ人だから世界最強やというね
ひとかけらもない 腰抜けなんです
そんな自信があったらね
もうまあそこらあちこちイラク人のいるところに行く必要もないし
そこら辺でイラク人を呼んでおいでおいでとか
楽しくバーベキューでもやりましょうとかね
君たちのイラクの音楽も結構面白いんだから
みんなで踊って踊りましょうとかね
そんなことするんですよ
自信あるんだったら だから自信ないんだから
もう片っ端から殺していくんです
はい  自分に対する自信が最弱
それで最弱の場合は 自分に対してはまるっきり自信がない
その場合 何を選ぶかというと
自分の破壊 いじめから
それで自分を破壊しようとする
俺がダメだとかね 俺が何やったってうまくいくわけじゃないんだとかね
どうせダメに決まってるんだとかね
ネガティブ思考になっちゃって
自分をどんどんどんどん蝕んでいくんです
自分がそうやらせている
やってるんです これが例えばこの精神的な病気
落ち込み 引っ込み ネガティブ思考っていうのは
もう自信がない人間のやり方なんです
自信があったらもう引っ込むんじゃなくて
誰かぶん殴るんですよ
例えば会社で何か嫌味を言われたら
自信があったらぶん殴って辞めるぞと
この会社はそれ怒りでしょ
何だお前は 辞める 辞めてやるぞと
せっかく辞めるんだから何かやって辞めるそうでいて
何かぶん殴ってでももう椅子一つで壊してでも出ていく
だって自信があるんですよ
自信がない人はものすごく引っ込んで自分を責めるんです
責めて自己破壊する はい
自分に対する自信がゼロ
期待が全く  それで自分に対してはまるっきりも自信がない
見込みはゼロ  1日も生きていられるというぐらいも自信はない場合は何を選ぶかというと
自分自身の  自分自身の殺しを選ぶんです
だから人間が落ち込むと堕落するというと
もうこれ以上は堕落できないところまで堕落したら
自殺を選ぶんです すべて怒りの世界だから我々にもあるでしょうね
自信ある人は喧嘩したりするし
これ自信なんかどんどんどんどん減っていっちゃうと危ないんですよ
どんどん選ぶ実がひどい結果選ぶんですよ
どんどん自信があると軽い軽い結果選ぶ
ぶん殴ったりとかね 喧嘩したりとか
軽い結果選ぶ それで警察官に怒られて済む
しっかりしなさいよとかね
自信が減っていくと もっとひどいことをする
もう裁判で終わったりとかね
刑務所に終わったりしたり
もっとちょっと減っちゃうと人を殺したりするもするし
もっと自信がなくてゼロになって見込みは何もない場合は自分で自分を殺しちゃうんですね
これがまあまあ もう厳密な分析はそんなもんですよ
まあそれ以上言うことはないんですけど
まあそれでも言います
はい 込みはあります うん
人は不幸になりたくない
だから 怒りの実ってなんで我々は怒りの実を取るんですかね
禁断の実ですよ それがもう美味しいんだったらしょうがないんですけどね
それの美味しくないんでしょ？人と殴ったってもね
気分が悪くなったっても
はい みんな不幸になりたくないはずでしょうし
はい  怒りによって不幸になって
しかし もう凝って不幸になっていくんですね
怒る原因は限りなくあるとしたっても
不幸になりたくないんだったらね
怒らなきゃいいのに やっぱり簡単に怒る
はい  わかっても絶対に
怒りが良くないとわかっても絶対やめないね
怒る はい  心は怒りの海に自由に泳ぐ魚のようです
我々の心っていうのはすごい自由ですけど
怒りの海に泳いでいるんです
だから心を魚に例えると
怒りという海で我々は泳いでいるんです
魚だから水から上げるのは嫌でしょ
だから人間が怒りをなくしてくださいと言うと嫌がるんです
だから怒りを応援すると結構人気ありますよ
と思い出した例なんですけど
平和運動しようと思っちゃうと
せいぜい10人も集まりませんよ
何か反対運動でもやってみてください
断固と反対とかいくらでも集まります
戦争だったったらいたわ簡単に賛成する
日本人が平和主義だととんでもないインチキ嘘を言っていて
イラクに軍隊を送ることになった時点でもうせっかく自分の軍隊行くんだから
やっぱりということでもう戦争賛成になっちゃうんです
簡単ですね 心変えるのは
ですから 怖いんですよ
人間は 人間をちょっと何て言いますか
興奮させてまとめようと思っちゃうと
怒りが一番簡単なんです
怒りを煽ぐともいくらでももう人が集めてくる
例えば聖書でも旧約聖書に怒りで組み立てているんです
怒り 憎しみ 憎しみと ただですまんそうと
おびえとか脅しとかね
なぜかで その方が人が聞いてくれると
永遠な火に燃えるそうとお前はと言うと
これ怒りでしょう それで怖くなって
だったら信じますよということになるんです
だから世間 世界ではどこでも怒りっていうのは結構
激しい感情で人は集まりやすい状態になっています
ということは 我々は怒りという海で泳いでいる魚なんです
魚だから海から上げるのはものすごく嫌がるんです
だからいくら怒るなよと言っても聞いてくれるはずがないんです
はい  になるのはわかっての
不幸になるとわかっても怒るんです
はい  はい で それで幸福になりたいと思ってまた怒るんですよ
これまた面白いんです
幸福になりたくて怒りで頑張っちゃうんです
はい  どうしようもないとしょうがないと怒る
それでまた怒りの理由を言うんです
どうしようもないんではないか
この場合は とかね しょうがないでしょとかね
とにかく何か言って怒る
旦那を怒鳴ってこなきゃ
もう不倫でもしたらどうしようかと
幸福のために怒鳴るんだぞと
いで怒鳴っちゃう 怒鳴りは怒りだからやっぱり不倫するんですよ
で そういうことでもう人間っていうのはとにかくそういうふうなことで必ずも怒るんだぞと
絶対怒らないではいられないと何か決まってるような感じなんです
そんなにも怒りが美味しいんでしょうかという問題なんですよ
ひと欠けらもいいことないんですよ
はい 次  またまた快感をもたらす
理由は怒り自体はこの快感快感をもたらすんですよ
旦那にキャンキャン怒って怒鳴りつけると
本人がすごいいい快感なんです
それから旦那どんな反応するか
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
あの瞬間の快感 だから怒っちゃうんです
はい だから怒りの味っていうのは快感ですね
はい 次  生きる衝動を与え
これで結構生きていられます
怒ると 人生は無常だとかね
生きることには意味がないとかね
どんな尊い話なんかはもう聞く暇がないんです
怒りさえあればもう頑張って生きるんです
はい  失敗と言い訳を作る
失敗したら不幸になったら
これ 怒りっていうのは結構いいわけになるんですね
これが まあ大体何かうまくいかなかったらね
まあもうこのせいだ あのせいだとかね
いろんな人に当たったりとかね
そうやってこの怒りを使っていいわけをするんです
はい  無知の直弟子なので縁は切れない
裏切らない  怒りっていうのは
この無知の直弟子直系なんですね
直系子なんです だから直系だからもう縁は切れないでしょ
自分が生んだ子供と縁は切れんだからね
まだ怒りというのは決して裏切れないんですよ
100%破壊してくる
自分を殺してくれる やむきれないんですね
欲とはちょっと違うんです
はい  欲と違って無理をしなくてもできる
うん 無理をしなくても大丈夫
怒りっていうのはすぐもう衝動というか
すぐ現れますからね 例えば
なんとか変な音楽でも楽しく聞きたければ
いろいろ勉強しなくちゃあかんでしょうね
で 例えば音楽演奏でも聞こうかなと思うと
またそこで演奏をやっている場所に行ったり
前もってチケットを予約したり
買ったりとか 結構準備やら必要でしょうし
あるいはもう演奏に聴きに行っても
もしかするとそんなに座った場所が悪くて
音はきれいに聞こえなかったとか
いろいろありますけどね
だから欲の場合はもうちょっと無理いっぱいあるんですね
怒りはそうじゃないんですよ
そんな苦労しなくてもすぐ怒れます
例えば おいしく食べたいと思ったら結構無理あるでしょ
おいしく食べたければ丁寧に材料を選んで買ってきて
丁寧に料理をして食べないと
これ大変です 疲れる 怒る場合はあれ
ぶん殴っちゃえばいいんだからね
もう簡単です だから無理なく実行できます
簡単に快楽になるので
簡単に快感になるので
発散の一途です  うん だから怒りは言っても信じられないほど簡単に快感作るんです
だからとっても恐ろしいことで
だから人類が現れたから今までもう人殺し
戦争 破壊  1でもなくなったわけないでしょ
で 何十年も苦労して やっと街を作ったり
橋を作ったり 道路を作ったりと
これは10分以内で破壊する
爆弾落として 人間を成長させるために
幸福にするために 科学はほとんどもうもう 1000分の1 1万分の1も能力を注いでないんです
でも大量破壊兵器作ろうと思っちゃうと
暗闇でも飛ばせる飛行機作ろうと思っちゃうと
ものすごい知識人 天才の連中が集めて
すごいお金かけて 国民のお金かけて
その国民を殺すために兵器を開発する
だから科学実験 科学能力は大体もう80%以上人を殺すために使っているんです
漏れる情報でちょっと人を助かると
ということで この大変ですよ
怒りは だからそれが快感なんですよ
例えば原子爆弾を発見作るバカっていうのは知ってるでしょうに
こんな悪いととんでもないんだと
科学者だから でもあのバカたちは作るんだから
徹夜しながら だからそのちっぽけな快感にやられちゃうんです
はい  弱き者にも自信弱くもの
弱き者にも勇気があります
自信が弱の場合  生きる自信が薄れている弱き者は
怒りによって勇気をつけられる
これなんですよ 生きる自信がない人が怒りを作って簡単だからね
これで勇気作るんです
ごまかすんです 私には勇気があるんだぞと
怒ると勇気があるのごとく見えるでしょ
だから弱いに決まってますよ
私はこの小学生の時でも
仲間の子供たちを見てね
まあ時々人に殴りたいと思って
いろんな小さないろんなものを持ったりとかね
ちょっとあの 何て言いますか
刃物を持ったりとかしているんですよ
とにかく体格はあるんです
私は学校で一番体が小さかったんです
あの連中を遊んだりすると潰れるぐらいすごい体格でしたけど
けど でも私は何も持ってないのに
私より倍も筋肉つけてて体も大きくている連中がもう何か道具
武器を持ってるんですね
でもあの誰も私をいじめたことも殴ったことも一度もなかったんですけど
あの 昔話だからね みんなお互いに仲良くかわいがって
心配し合って生活するんだからね
だから体がでっかいだからといって怖いっていうことはまるっきりないんです
体がでかいわりに頭が悪いんだからね
私は裏で勉強教えてあげないと
で それもありましたし
で 私は ある同級生に言ったんですよ
結局はお前臆病者でしょうと
ったら臆病は何言うんでしょうかと
だってお前はこれ刃物持ってるでしょうと
怖くなくちゃそんな持てないでしょうと
私は持っていないんだよと
全然怖くないんだから
言うとそれでも負けちゃったんです
本人は やっぱりこの臆病者っていうのはもう結構この怒りでもって勇気つけるんです
鉄砲ぐらい持ってれば勇気あるでしょ
あのピストルとかね だから皆様もあの法律を犯しているヤクザとかね
そういう暴力団とか みんな自信があっていいなと
とんでもない逆なんです
全く自信がないんだから
この怒りの態度をとっているんです
脅しの態度をとっているんです
はい  被害者の役をあえて
これ一つ これからいろいろ被害者の役をあえて選ぶ
被害者を演じる あれ 怒りですよ
はい 犠牲を好むな かっこつけて
まあどうしようもない
まあ私にはまあ まあそんな
まあみんなやればいいんじゃないか
みんな昇格すればいいんで言わないか
私はもう普通の社員でいいんだとかね
これでね かっこつけるんですよ
犠牲を好んで どうやっても何のことない
ただ怒りで弱みを隠してるだけ
うん  謙虚さを表に出さないから
これもやるんですね あまり表に出てこない
いいもう私はいいです
いいですとかね で 謙虚さ演じるんですね
これも怒りなんです みんな人間っていうのは
やっぱりどう元気とかしゃべってくれた方が気持ちいいのに
みんなこそこそと後ろで後ろに行っちゃうと
入った人にとって気分が悪いんですよ
そこでこの怒りの人はね
謙虚さ演じて舞台を表舞台から降りるんですね
これで勇気あるんです
裏舞台でははい  インテリかぶりで何でもできるできるやになるが
何もしない評論家評論家になる
うん それからインテリかぶりをするんです
だからインテリかぶりをしたら弱みが見えなくなっちゃうんです
私ならそんなくだらんことやらんぞとかね
あんた方何やってるんですか？バカバカらしいことを何やってるんでしょうか
偉そうなことを言う だから自分は何でもできるやで演じるんですけど
何もやらない ただ批判するだけで非難するだけで評論家になるだけ
これもこの弱い人の勇気付けなんです
それで勇気があるのごとく生きていられます
うん またあります それ自信ゼロの人の場合
自身が薄れていく 弱き者への怒りによって勇気をつける
被害妄想にふける  自信がゼロな人は被害妄想にふけるんです
はい  精神的な病を作る
それから自分がダメだ
自分の悪口みんな言ってるんだとかね
世界は細菌だらけで 自分には生きていられないんだとかね
そういう何とかして精神的な病気をわざわざわざわざ自分で作るんですよ
それから生きる自信があるんです
面白いことに だって その病気に隠れているんだから
言い訳をするでしょ？うちの子はこういうことだから仕事できんだそうとか
お母さん怒らないでしょ
それもよくまあやるんで
病気を作るんですね うん
被害妄想 ネガティブ思考により体の健康を失い
心体的な病  これもありますよ
だから被害妄想があるとネガティブ思考があると体が肉体的に病気になるんですよ
がんになったり いかゆになったり
いろいろありますよ 糖尿病になったり
早くも どんな病気でも高血圧であろうが何であろうとも
ほとんどこの怒りが作ってくれるんです
それで見事な言い訳やります
私は糖尿病だから 私はがんだからしょうがないじゃねえかということで
もう自分がもう怒りの結果いただく
いわゆる自己破壊の結果をいただく
それが生きる勇気にするんですよ
もうバカというと もうもうあまりでしょうに
わざと体を壊して病気になって
それが生きる勇気にする
はい  苦しいことは決まっているが
本人は楽しいという勇気をつけられる
そんなことやると苦しいに決まってるでしょうに
被害妄想であれもいやこれもいやだと
楽しいわけないでしょ
楽しくないんだったらやめろと言いたいんだけど
本人にはそれしか生きる道がないんです
だからそれで生きてるんです
だから親も親戚もしょうがない
うちの子はちょっと病気だから
精神的に だから周り親戚にどう手の打ちようもないんですよ
医者にも誰にも手の打ちようはないんです
なぜかというと 本人が自分で怒って自分を破壊して
そういう病気を作っているんだから
だから仏教の答えは勝手にしろということなんです
はい  弱き者に自信ゼロ
また続きやります 自信ゼロの場合は
怒りにも自己破壊にも失敗する人がいる
これが 2番目です あのある人が怒りにも失敗する
大体失敗しないはずなんですけど
自己破壊にも失敗する
もうもうもうとんでもないバカなんです
怒ったら壊れてしまうのは当たり前
100%確率性あるのに
そういうとんでもないバカがいるんですよ
次に説明あると思いますけど
被害妄想に陥っても ネガティブ思考で精神を痛めたり
痛みをつけたりしても
なかなか肉体は  いるんですよ
とことん被害妄想では
でもなかなか体が病気にならないんです
かわいそうに 言い訳成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
はい  精神的に狂わない
そんなこと思っちゃうと精神的に狂って病気になるでしょ
この人は病気にならない
とんでもない汚い思考ばっかり回転しているんですけど
やっぱりそれでも正気なんです
これ とんでもない失敗なんです
はい  怒られしょうか 欲が邪魔をする
なぜかというと 俺がダメだ
もうどうともこうでと思いながらも
まあもしかするとというところもどこかであるんです
だから力がちょっと弱めるんです
怒りで力が弱めるんだから
体破壊することももう
だからもう甘いんですね
だから球を投げるんですけど
きちんとシュッとももう一流のピッチャーのようには投げないんです
はい  このような人が自殺を選ぶのです
どうしようもない だから自殺を選ぶんです
体ぐらい病気になってくれればありがたいのに
お母さん壊してくれるのに
病もないわ 元気ピンピンは
でも頭がもうむちゃくちゃ変な思考でいるわ
怒りでいっぱいは そうすると自殺しちゃうんですね
だからこの失敗の失敗者が自殺するんです
いわゆる手加減の自己破壊にさえも失敗する
だから手加減の自己破壊ができないんですよ
みんな手加減自己破壊しているのに
これはうまくいかない
だからもう自殺するんです
はい  人生の未来 自己破壊の怒りさえも中途半端
そういう人はもう人生だけではなくて
怒りさえも中途半端なんです
だから自殺するしか道がないんですよ
もう 怒るんだったらもうしっかり怒れっていうこと
それもできんで中途半端
勉強するんだったらしっかり勉強する
中途半端なんですよ だから学校に俺が勉強したくない
やめるという子どもたちは結構うまくいくでしょうに
堂々とやめたと怒ってはっきりしてますよ
中途半端じゃないんです
それで勉強は大嫌いんだけど
ぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ学校に行く
行って勉強もしないし
もうどうにもならん それ自殺するはめになりますよ
だって仲間はいじめるでしょ
だから先生がお前勉強するんですか？あるいは寝ているどちらかですかと
はっきりしないんですね
そういう人々は自殺しますよ
だからもう人格で言えば最悪なんです
怒りでもはっきりすればもうはっきりするんだからね
まあはい  自殺を図っても勇気がなくてできない人
何を何も考えずやってしまうこと 2種類
それ自殺願望者が 2種類ですよ
だからどうせ腰抜けだから自殺ししたいんだけどできない
なんか怖いとか そういうのもいて
まあ別に自殺しか道がないんだと思って
パッと自殺するっていう人もいますよ
いるんだから自殺しようと思って
包丁やら何か持っていて
やっぱり怖い 痛いであろうと思うとやめる
もう何考えてるんですか？人生嫌になってもう自殺しようと思っている
痛いのはなんで嫌がる？もうあまりにも変でしょ
時々なんとか林何森とありますね
富士山の方で樹海なんかにいて自殺しようと思って
やっぱり怖いなと 森はと戻ってくるんです
どれほどおかしいかというと
人格的に せっかく自殺してやるぞと言ったならば行けばいいのに
それぐらいもできないんですよ
だから帰ってきてどうやって生きていますかね
あれ 自慢できる？はい
自殺者の勇気と 手加減を持って自己破壊もできない
これ自殺 自殺者っていうのは
勇気といったのはちょっとおかしく入っただけで
もう手が手加減 何でしたっけ？ 手加減
自己破壊もできない 私たちみたいに
はい  はい ポジティブになるところは論外ですが
ネガティブ思考にも失敗
うん 考え方 ポジティブ思考といったってほんの論外だから
そういう人にはね でも真面目にネガティブ思考もできん
はい  完全に認める  完全に認めがないんで
自分に対してはね はい
怒りの快感も生きる勇気は与えてくれない
そこでちょっと怒っていても
中途半端な怒りでしょ
快感がないんですよ だからもう自殺することになるんです
うん  私は予測も期待もできない
あっても向かう自信はない
うん それでまあ だから先っていうのはもう大体怒りの快感でもなければ生きていられませんよ
例えばお母さんたちがすごい元気で
もう 10人分ぐらいの頑張るでしょうね
だからちっちゃな子ども
赤ちゃんぐらいと子育てはすごい快感なんですよ
だからもう 10人分でも仕事できる １
日も30分寝ることできなくなっても
あんなあんなことないんです
子供は泣いちゃって またもう面倒見る
あれがやっぱり快感をエネルギーつけてくれますよ
愛情が私の子供やということで
だからその同じことで
そうでなきゃ人は生きていられません
だから この自殺する人々には
怒りっていうのは簡単に快感を作れるのに
それも出てこないんですね
はい だから生きていられない
ことを勇気にする  うん
だから何かちょっと一つでも勇気があればいいんじゃない？いいんじゃないかなということで
まあ自殺を決めるんです
本人にとってはたったそれだけなんで
勇気の行為は 一生一回勇気を出して外を出たと
ちっちゃな子供でも勇気を出して一人で電車に乗るとかやってるでしょうに
それぐらいもできんです
たった選んだ勇気は自殺なんです
うん はい  欲と怒りの加減
それで加減もちょっと勉強しましょう
欲と怒りの加減  限りなく欲も怒りも増す
この大体一般的に言いますよ
欲にはキリがないとかね
金はいくらあっても足らんとかね
本当はそうじゃないんです
怒りにも欲にもやっぱりこの限りはあるんです
限りなく増幅することはないんです
はい  リミットの赤線があります
怒りはここまでやと これ以上は増えませんよというリミットがあるんです
欲もここまでやと これ以上はできんというリミットがあります
その赤線を越えると 欲にしろ怒りにしろ
生命はその原因で死ぬのです
死ぬんです 赤線取っちゃうと
例えば欲張っても欲張ってもいいんだけど
赤線超えちゃうと欲で死ぬんです
まあ心臓発作を起こしたりとか
例えば間違って宝くじでも当たったら危ないんですよ
もしかすると心臓発作を起こす可能性あります
だからそうやって このものすごい自分に管理できんほど欲が入り込んでくると
もう死んじゃうんです
体耐えられないんです
怒りの場合も ある加減で怒っても胃が悪くなるとかね
がんになったとかね そういうふうに壊れてはいくんだけど
あまりにもパッと怒っちゃうと
いきなり全部機能停止して死ぬんです
だから怒りと欲には一応加減があります
はい  しかし 限りなく欲も限りなくしかし
限りなく欲も限りなく怒りも実行する人も
なのに限りなく欲を実行する人いるんですよ
何百億 何兆ぐらいお金あって
まだまだ商売やってるとかね
あれってどうやって頑張ってるんでしょうかね
よく頑張ってますよ 怒りにもそういうケースはいくらでもあります
それから例はあると思いますけど
なかったら言います はい
外から影響を受けている
それで例を書いてないんですね
例えばこのまあ 限りなく人を殺す
無様に人を殺す 私たちだったら
まあせいぜい一人殺したら二人殺すって論理的にできるんでしょ
それ以上できない 見つかっちゃたりする
あるいは自分を殺されたりする
欲で銀行強盗したっても
10個ぐらいはできんでしょうに
せいぜい １個で終わっちゃいます
２つはできないんです
だからそんなもんなのに
いくらでも金儲けて いくらでも世界の資源を我が物にする人が世の中に今もいるでしょうに
そこでいくら人殺しても足らなくて
もっともっと殺す もう無様に殺す連中もいるんです
これどういうやり方かというと
この外からエネルギーの影響を受けて増幅するんです
自分だけの怒りではもう自分が死ぬんです
それで外から影響を受けるんです
援助 それでできるんです
はい  他人の協力がなければアドルフヒトラーは成り立ちません
イエスとイエロドリ帝愛などにも怒りの行為はできます
例えばアドルフヒトラーいるでしょう
いたでしょうね どれぐらい人を殺したんですかね
なんとか何とか作ったりね
ガスチェンバー作ってもうユダヤ人を殺したり
もう数え切れない 一人にそんなことできる？できない
自分がその怒りのエネルギーで死ぬんですよ
発作を起こして それでみんなの怒りとネットワークを作るんですよ
他の連中の怒りと そこでヒトラーらがみんなの怒りをあおぐだけでいいんです
我々はドイツ人が偉大なる民族であるとか
お前らはもうドイツ人としてプライドを持つべきやと
このネズミどもたちにはもう負けてはいけませんとかね
言うとそうだそうだと思って
ドイツ人がもう怒りのネットワークを作る
それでいくらでも破壊できる
一人の軍人でも大胆なことができるのは
軍隊 国 国民が支えるという自己暗示のおかげです
時々一人の軍人がすごい勇気を出してたくさん破壊してくる時で事実あったんですね
一人にそんなことできるのかね
敵軍のところの中に入ってとかね
敵の領域に入ったりとかね
やっぱり一人の力は一人の力なんですけど
自分一人の破壊力が緩和するんですよ
裏にみんな支えてくれるんだと
みんなの怒りで だからこの怒り
カンナ祭なんですね みんなで怒りましょうと
そうすると一人の人間じゃなくて
もうもう 100人でも殺せますよと
一人が 100人殺しちゃうともう耐えられないんです
その怒りは それでみんなとつなげてネットワークを作るんです
例えば 1本の棒 こんな風な 1本の棒だったらもう立てないでしょ？落ちるでしょうし
これは何か台にさせておけば
台の力で立ってるでしょうね
そうするとこいつにはすごい力があるんですよ
折っても折っても折れないんです
例えば この上に座ろうと思ったら怪我するでしょ
でも座れないよ 倒れますから
そう それに付けとけたらどうですかね
もう人殺せます これでそうやってこの緩和して
他人の力借りて無限に広げるんです
怒りと欲は この働き勉強した方がいいんです
だから決していいことじゃないんですよ
この軍事主義とかね 愛国主義とか
あれは地獄の道なんですよ
みんなで渡れば怖くないということなんですよ
はい  宗教 民族感情などに由来すると
一人の人間の大量破壊
自爆テロなどができる
それからこの我々 緩和されて宗教も使ったりする
神様のためならということで殺しに行く
あるいは私は人を殺してない
神様の命令であって あるいは神を侮辱している人を殺しているだけですと
そういう気持ちになるといくらでも勇気があって殺されます
だからこれで大量破壊
自爆テロ 何でもできる
後押しがなければ自殺しか選択
そういう後押しがない場合は
破壊したい 人も殺したい
でも一人の人間 何もできんでしょうに
例えば学校にいる連中をみんな殺してやりたい気持ちになる
学校にいるいじめられた
学校の連中はみんな殺してやりたい
できるわけないでしょ
自分がいじめられる側だから弱いでしょうに
それで仲間来る？では君と一緒に行って学校みんな殺しましょう
誰も仲間はないでしょ
それで神様のためと言って宗教も後押ししないでしょ
どうすればいいんですか？それは自殺するんです
学校のみんな殺す代わりに自分が自殺するんです
だから後押しがない場合は自殺します
最近 日本では自殺願望者の公園があるのです
日本ではなんか自殺願望者の後援団とかね
まあそういうグループもあります
インターネットでとかね
自殺したい人々はお互いにメールを交換したりして
そこで仲間的にまたちょっと支えてもらって
後押ししてもらって自殺する
一人で怖いんだから三人で自殺するとかね
あまりにも腰抜けなんですけど
ということもあります
そうなると 自殺を動かすまでエネルギーを蓄していない人にもできるようになる
そうやって自殺願望の仲間ができちゃうと
一人自殺できない人にもできるようになるんです
ですから この後押し 後援というのはすごいことなんですよ
ヒットラーもドイツ人が周りの国々が応援したんだから
とんでもないことをできたんです
ビンラディンにも宗教と
何 サウジアラビアがね
後押ししているんだから
もう何でもできる それから他のイスラム信者さんたちも
もう後押しはしてくれる
でなきゃ何もできんでしょうに
だからこのこのネットワークはもう無限大の危険性に広げます
一人の人間が怒ったっても
もう誰もね 気にもしない
例えば あるアメリカ人が日本人に対してカンカ怒ったりする
痛くも痒くもないでしょ
しかし ブッサンがカンカン怒ったりすると痛いところじゃないね
その場合は 日本はそのまま経済的に破壊する可能性あるでしょうね
軍隊は来なくても なぜかというと
あの人にも後押しがあるんです
だから力無限大 それ力も自分だけの怒りなんです
だからイラク潰したのある一人の個人の怒りなんですよ
一人の個人の怒りが後押しによって国際的な怒りにして
そういう見せかけで破壊に行ったんです
はい そのポイントでブッダの助言が入ります
この後押しはすごいんだから
外からの影響を受けると
心は桁違いに  そういうこと
外から影響来るんだったら
自分の心っていうのは桁違いへ力を発揮するんです
一人では力ないんですよ
誰か誰か仲間がいると
ものすごく勇気付けられて
心がみるみるうちに力になるんです
はい ...向上に明るい人間になるための他人の利と善友を求める
仏法を聞く 強い仲間と付き合うなどことを推薦
だからこれしなさいと
人を殺すために仲間を作るんじゃなくて
自己破壊するために仲間を作るんじゃなくて
明るくて人格向上して
ものすごい幸福で楽しくて
空を飛んでいる鳥のごとく
人生はすごい気楽に生きるという目的にして
それ人格を向上しなくちゃいけない
怒るばかりには何もできんだから
怒らない人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
ですから それも一人ではね
無理だから いくらなんでも
それで戦友を作るんですよ
いい仲間 頭のいい仲間を作る
それからよく仏教は徹底的に勉強する
そういうことでかなり力になるんです
それですごい幸せになる
で それで仏教 お釈迦様はそれ推薦するんですよ
涅槃まで体験できるんだと
いい友達に出会えばと教えているんです
はい  この道を選べば どんなにダメな人間であっても最高の人生
そう このこれだけ選べば
講演者をね どんなダメな人間でもダメって全然気にする必要ない
だから私は自殺はバカにして喋ったんですよ
どうったことない 普段は日本の社会ではすごい真剣に扱う問題でしょうに
この落ち込みやら被害妄想やら
私はバカバカげてしか喋ったんです
何のことない もうどんなダメな人間でも
ちょっと良い講演者がついてくればすぐもう立派になるんです